[Music]
hi my name is Lucy - and I'm the
executive chef at lunch area in Brooklyn
tortas it's a traditional dish from
Mexico there's different kinds of Cortez
in Mexico depending on the region there
are mostly famous in Mexico City
it's made with bread beans protein
sometimes a little bit of cheese and
that is it there is a traditional bread
we use it's called de la da most of the
tourists come from the baguette you find
in Poland juries it's a wider type of
bread than the baguette form you find
stands of tortoise all over the city but
most of the time it's maybe the same
type of bread there are tortoise
certainly in New York City but we're
taking the tortoise to a next level
using our skills and experience so we
have the lamb belly torta which is
called any Apple buff lamb is a really
[ __ ] it's a special meat tricky
sometimes so we took the challenge of
making it really nice bracing it
overnight marinated for 48 hours prior
to cooking
we mix garbanzo beans or chickpeas with
black beans and that's what we smear on
the bottom inside of the bread can we
put the roasted lamb belly we cook the
belly in a barbacoa style I'm a big fan
of barbacoa from the city of Chicago
which is east of Mexico City we use
people tomatillos and then what how
could she string cheese on a torta and
then we serve that with a Jew which is
the lamb stock the consomme so people
can actually deep the torta into there's
you and just make it really nice and
juicy we also have the venom E which is
a play on bonhomie
traditional Vietnamese sandwich in
Southeast Asia so we took a nice piece
of brisket salted for 48 hours and then
put a double roll into the biscuit brace
it and we get this really nice pink
color around the brisket with adobo
sauce on top we take two slices of the
brisket and then same setting all with
the same settings mayo smear on the
bread black beans with avocado leaf on
the bottom the black beans have always
have to be on the bottom and then we
have bound me ingredients which is red
cabbage lots of cilantro and slices of
how menu what we really want is we want
to show that your toes can be made in
many different ways I have a background
in French cooking and Japanese cooking
and I wanted to bring that into la
langue Sharia combining those
experiences with the traditional way of
eating tortillas which I actually did I
grew up eating tortas and I wanted to
combine both of a traditional way of
making tortillas in my experience into
Manchuria
[Music]
you